I have absolutely no idea how to start
this video because I never thought I'd
be in the situation's I'm in which is
that I made a YouTube channel that now
has 25,000 people subscribed to it how
literally I can't think of a single way
that's intelligent to open this video
other than saying I have a I have 25,000
people subscribe to my channel
thousands of people watch videos I make
and I am unbelievably grateful there's
literally I can't say anything other
than that I am so happy about where this
channel has gone I am so proud of what
it has become
and and the amazing group of people that
have stopped watching these videos thank
you before I can say thank you so much
for watching my channel
you know nothing clever much like most
videos really on this channel nothing
clever but thank you so much you know
you've made me really happy by by
watching my videos and engaging and
leaving comments and sending me really
lovely messages no I'm not gonna cry
thank you so much for support you've
given this channel and in some poetry
way of saying thank you I'm going to
answer some questions that you've sent
me so there's no intro that let's just
get on with it shall we
leo is asked if the channel does well
and the opportunities presented what I
consider YouTube full time yes
absolutely yes
in fact my current pseudo plan because
it's not really a plan when I graduate
is to do YouTube and video making
full-time for doing some science related
videos on my channel also doing
Commission's working with institutions
like Durrell yeah basically I love doing
this Sam Rana asked if I was a girl for
a day what's the first thing I could do
if there are no restrictions honestly I
think I would just walk down the street
and like be a woman in the world and see
how it is different from being a man
because I empathize with a lot of gender
issues but I don't think you can
understand unless you walk 200 miles and
their shoes kind of things so I'd be
really interested to see how the world
is different just by being a woman but
that isn't the answer you were expecting
you filthy minded people
Sean James Cameron asked where do you
see your channel in 3 years time
instantly sean has a really cool channel
called the horticultural channel which
is like a gardening show and YouTube
check him out in three years I imagine I
hope
that this channel will have 100,000 plus
subscribers they'll be making regular
videos about different aspects of
science but also still making videos
about parts of my life and things I find
interesting in particular I'd love to
making videos about film and also in
three years time like to be doing this
full-time along with other cool video
chanteys maybe even putting short films
or working on features three years is a
long time and at least asked what's the
best film I've seen that I think a lot
of people haven't heard of I'm not I'm
not record it knee to cinema my
housemates are actually really into
niche stuff I think the film which I've
seen which not enough people seen not
necessarily of heard of is Sicario which
came out 2015 and was a really tall
tight action thriller and it was shot by
Roger Deakins he's like my favorite DP
of all time and it looks amazing see if
you can any asked what's your favorite
quote I'm not one to go in for quotes
really but I really like hard work beats
talent when talent doesn't work hard
CK 101 and one asked if I take a one-way
trip to Mars no because I wouldn't be
able to see my friends and go a friend
and family again and I really like them
even though it'd be really awesome to be
on Mars to do a mile what me I like her
too much a two-way trip now that's
different
dota 2 moment asked how do I manage my
time every day at the moment I'm not
very good at it I feel like I'm wasting
a lot of time on YouTube in particular I
tend to write out a to-do list or I try
to a start of each day including some
stuff that's easily tipped off but it
basically motivates me with some youtube
stuff some PhD stuff so I'm just life
admin stuff and just check it off one by
one and then do like her on the weekend
trying to a bit of a meta plan right
I'll distracting I want to do that week
but like I said I think I need to look
at how to make that more efficient Peter
Robinson I'm not gonna read your
question out but Marion on Twitter asked
loads of questions first one what's the
best part about doing a PhD the freedom
it gives you if I want to I can just
sleep in until 10:00 or 11:00 and then
rock up to university I then have to
work late to catch up on anything I need
to do but definitely the freedom
secondly what kind of people do a PhD
suit people who like that freedom people
who are curious about the world and want
to know more about it 3 where's your
favorite place to travel easy Island of
Jersey 4 is there a movie that you watch
over and over again I have to think
about this but I think the film I've
watched most is the matrix when I used
to paint
to paint miniatures I would put on the
background so I think I've watched the
matrix about hundreds of times literally
Leo studies is that a scientist that's
inspired me and why Jose Clerk Maxwell
who was this such another way to figure
in the history of physics I might have
to do a video on him but he was like
Newton level important and yet was a
really nice guy was good in a whole
bunch of different fields and you know
just by all accounts was I think there
was a quote that the perfect Victorian
Christian gentleman something and you
know there are different bits of that
that I didn't necessarily want but just
sounds like an all-around nice guy and
was really good at a subject I quite
like to be that have a gaming HD who's
your everyday life inspiration honestly
my parents crazy gamer asked who was I
inspired by what gave me the most
motivation in terms of who I was
inspired by definitely my parents again
but also teachers at my school my
debating where he was an English teacher
also did the debating Club another
teacher mrs. Cartwright who also did
that my science teacher my history
teacher mr. Harrison mr. bird like they
really launched me into questioning the
world and believing that I could be I
could be something and that in terms of
what motivates me that is it I wanted to
be something I want to leave a mark on
the world I want to leave the world a
better place than I found it and do
amazing things that's that's like my
motivation every day been Claridge out
of the Martian and interstellar which is
your favorite the Martian by a very very
very long way interstellar is not a very
good film
saucy Mayo amazing username
when's your over coming up and on a
scale of one to ten how nervous are you
at the moment I'm not feeling too
nervous my father is gonna be I mean
hopefully submitting in about 13 months
which means my Viper will being about 14
to 15 months issues I'll make a video
explaining the process at some point I'm
not feeling too nervous about it I'm
just anxious about actually getting
enough stuff into my thesis right now
I'll worry about the vive er in the
future that's future Simon's problem
Emma Jane cook would you rather be
attacked by big bear or a swarm of bees
I've seen the revenant swarm bees every
time they're gonna sting like hell but
I'm not gonna end up well you know
dead aleena did you expect the Spanish
Inquisition I don't think anybody does
and what do you do when you're sad
I generally attempt to YouTube I either
taught to buy my girlfriend or I will go
to eat you I actually have a playlist
I'll put it in the description of just
videos that make me laugh if I need a
laugh I'll just put it on shuffle and
watch something give it a watch if you
feel down the University of Wanda asked
a cluster of questions what would I do
to get John Wheeler is my own advisor or
supervisor change fields because he was
a theoretical astrophysicist are you
going to apply to be an astronaut for
NASA I can't cuz I'm not an American
citizen for Easter on the other hand not
gonna rule it out it's maybe what
University would you like to visit in
the u.s. probably Caltech because one of
my professors with my tutor a guy called
dr. Carter Garrett cutter always used to
come back from Pasadena with Caltech
bags and I'm always curious to see what
it was like really but you know I meant
oh I went to Rice University event so
that's anyone I've been to in the US
what things are there that normal people
think it easy to do with PhD find
impossible yeah sleep personally just
switch off I always have something
worried in here it's getting a bit of a
problem I need to learn how to just like
turn often read a book or something got
far too many things on the go swing
Barry rapid fire around pancakes or
waffles pancakes sheep or goats sheep
Apple or Android Android Tintin or
Asterix I love both but Asterix Jenni
Vasquez gee do you believe that we're
the only species in the galaxy the Drake
Equation tells me they're probably not
what's one crazy thing that you've
always wanted to do go hang gliding I've
done a lot of cool stuff but I've never
had a hang gliding and my biggest pet
peeve people who don't care liliane
point asked what are we her to be doing
in 10 years time 10 years is a really
long time I don't know hopefully in 10
years I'll be married with a small kid
and a dog maybe a cat I quite like both
and making videos full-time and maybe
writing books
I don't know having really nice garden
what 10 years of I don't want to think
how far in the future and how did you
discover the vlogbrothers I honestly
can't remember I think I just doubled
across one that video isn't like the
suggestions bar because I or it might
have been that I I kept seeing the word
nerdfighter on Charlie McDonald's videos
and then I looked up all that men and
then started watching our videos and
naturally became a nerdfighter dawn may
who incidentally is a PhD student at the
University of York and has her own blog
which I put down there in the doobly-doo
has asked apart from how physics what
areas of physics or science do I like to
keep up on I like to keep up of fusion
because that was actually the reason I
went in to do physics read I like what
one motivations even though it's more of
an engineering problem the physics
problem other than that exoplanets are
really cool and spaceflight generally
Joe Souki asked did my girlfriend like
for her Victoria Secret present the
answer is yes I'm not gonna say any more
than that
ready himmat asked how do i balance
working out and studying well at Oxford
and is it easy in our next to it's
definitely easier now for one thing I
didn't do it that seriously in Oxford I
went to the gym a couple of times a week
where I could mostly is a stress relief
and just to get like unplug on out my
phone with me Oxford's the central gym
isn't very good because most colleges
have their own jeans but some pieces
didn't hear the university's central gym
is phenomenal it is it's a free I think
if they invested some like 4 million
pounds of it so it's incredibly
facilities I also been taking it much
more seriously terms of diet and
workouts at the moment I'm trying to go
to three times a week and doing a lot of
strength stuff so 5x5 routines squat
bench
pull-up deadlift I'm moving into
deadlifts light a bit and then also in
terms of diet I'm trying to cut down for
the summer I've set myself girl trying
to lose 10 kilos by the start of July
and I'm making progress towards that you
know
I think I've lost about a kilo and a
half already but I can easily put that
back on in fact I probably really have
because I had a cold recently you know
how I know you just want to like feed it
but yeah so a lot of a lot of strength
stuff and trying to lose weight at the
same time up until recently I was
focused on like gaining mass and I cut
pretty quite big so 90 kilos was the
heaviest I ever got I'm now currently
trying to turn down to about 73 the
other thing that makes it easy here in
Exeter is have been doing a PhD means
you're much more flexible than doing it
on the ground because that undergrad you
have lectures and classes you have to
turn up to at the moment the only thing
that's like concrete in my diary apart
from seeing stuff is I have a
supervision once a week on a Thursday
morning with my main supervisor you know
and then I can work evenings I did work
in mornings the afternoons at night
whenever I want so you know much more
flexible to go to the gym Mike Dworkin
asked about a point in my draw my life
video where I talked about how I didn't
like maths I like the humanities and
there's there a tipping point and how he
like got into it the physics honestly
there wasn't really a tipping point I
sort of I mean I was never bad at maths
I just found it difficult I'm so when I
came talks but I just put loads and
loads of effort and I think resetting
first year when I did particularly pull
in one of the math modules getting over
that bump was was really significant for
my confidence and that actually liking
maths it was actually when I read
alice's adventures in numberland which
is why i recommend it to everybody that
was what sort of made me see mass in a
different way I would just wish I'd read
it when I was like in year 9 he wouldn't
made my life so much easier
Stefan and grace asked about what I'm
going to be hopefully doing off my PhD
kind of already answer this it's sort of
between academia and video making at the
moment I am much more leaning towards
the video making side of things I'm
trying to put a lot of effort into this
YouTube channel because well one of the
reasons is just because I like doing I
want to make the best stuff possible but
I also would like to be able to do this
full-time and that's that includes
making videos for this channel but also
ya doing commissioned work for other
channels and for other institutions so
charities like Daryl in basically doing
educational videos in a sort of
professional way
because I really enjoy doing this and
now I have an awful lot of kit a lot of
expertise to do it I think quite well so
you know I why wouldn't I want to do
that full time Tara Duggan asked who's
my favorite physicist difficult to pin
down I think it's probably between Paul
Dirac
and James Clerk Maxwell who again not
enough people have heard of also Marie
Curie Oscar Oscar was really boss bow
ties are [ __ ] cool in these name you
can't be angry at me asked what my
favorite song is now and ever
now right now at this very moment it's
either let thy hand be strengthened
which is by Handel and I did in a
concert last night definitely wasn't
like reading it or look on down from the
bridge by Mazzy Star of all time crying
out loud by meatloaf Tamil Ria's asked
do I believe in God and do I think the
physics will achieve the theory of
everything through society big questions
to answer in like a 10 second segment on
the theory of everything seems unlikely
well we're gonna get an approximation to
it at some point in terms of God I think
I talked about that a Jamie video I'll
have to try and find a link and put it
in the description because I'm not going
to go into that here I don't need
another flame war religious Harry asked
after I missed out on my Oxford PhD
place where what did I do to get back on
track that fortunately it wasn't
actually up here at longer period of
time where I was in the wilderness
finding out that I lost the offer and
then between that time and finding out
that I haven't had a place x2 was I
think about a week in that time I was
basically being led along by that this
idea that I might be going to a stir
it did take a book I mean I was actually
suffering from exhaustion coming from to
Exeter for the first couple of months
just from the stress of I think I think
the stress of of losing on the space but
also just everything going up into
finals and all the mental health issues
I've had having in final year yeah it
wasn't easy there wasn't anything in
particular that I did I just got on
threw myself into coming everyone we
said into the gym and in singing and
kept going so that's the best you can do
you just got to keep going forwards trip
Hudson asked how is my involvement in
music affects my academic life for my
dissertation research in all honesty I
think it has helped because it's given
me something else to focus on and think
about and also music to play in the
background because I've got to be
learning whatever piece that I'm gonna
be performing next Wednesday it doesn't
directly relate it but I think it's a
help Dan Paul asked if I hadn't found a
passion for physics what would I be
doing right now probably creative
writing enormously I was I used to write
a lot when I was when I was in school
and it's something that I might get back
into eventually when I find a few spare
minutes but yeah I think I probably
doing creative writing or me maybe drama
stuff I was really as a drama before I
before I had to drop it at GCSE maybe
that Marco Samuel Fabolous is asked
basically about specialization when did
I know about atmospheric physics I knew
enough about atmospheric physics in my
third year when I just really enjoyed
playing around with the basic flow
equations and how you can approximate it
and you can do really cool results and
see it in the real atmosphere and then
you like tend with lesser problem with
what with not quite so severe
approximations you know closer and
closer to the truth I don't know I just
I really liked then as I kind of
mentioned earlier before I went
university or an inter fusion I thought
that would be what I go into and to be
honest it doesn't matter if you have a
specialization in mind or if you just
like the subject you know you like you'd
like solving problems and knowing how
things work I give in a way that's kind
of better I think yeah don't worry about
it if you have a specialization and who
do I think Snoke is Plagueis does seem
the most logical answer
still not entirely convinced it's not
jar-jar though mark Cowan asked if there
was anything that blew my mind in
particular my degree I remember really
clearly a moment in a cosmology tutorial
we were talking about the expansion of
space and how normally you have this
idea is set in stone as a physics
student that nothing can go faster than
the speed of light you know but space
itself is expanding at a rate that's
only getting faster and faster and
faster and that means that there are
areas of space that we can see that we
will never reach because even if we were
to set up the speed of light space will
have expanded whose expanding faster
than we can get towards it was a weird
concept to explain but yeah I just
remembered that made me feel really
small insignificant that's like and
whatever other fight ten duck sized
horses are one horse-sized duck a horse
sized duck sounds absolutely terrifying
and no ten ten duck sized horses you can
just like kick them gleb I'm not gonna
[ __ ] not your surname sorry asked what
would I do so he gave me a million
pounds if I had to do stuff with it
personally I would probably like try and
invest it make a movie if I like in the
real world if it was just given to me I
definitely give some of it to Durrell
some of it to charities like the RSPCA
in the brook and ideally I'd like to do
something like an educational fun as
well actually that'd be cool a better
you know like um almost like a Kiva like
a microfinance kind of thing but for
educational purposes and then I'd also
try and make a movie and do I like Top
Gear the old one yes yeah when it's not
being racist it's it's actually pretty
fun like one of my favorite episodes
ever was the America roadtrip and also
the episode with a damn fan were they
have to make cars into boats if that
sounds like complete madness and haven't
seen it go watch it it's on YouTube it's
amazing a lastly slothy Queen asked
what's my favorite part video making
are you there the technical side of it
like getting everything set up for me
it's why I want to be I'm interested in
being a director of photography for the
short film I'm doing and further stuff
but I think it's really gonna be the
comments I love getting the feedback
from you guys and the interaction I see
in the comment section you're talking to
each other as well as talking to me and
you know giving feedback on the video
it's that interaction that's why I love
YouTube so much because it's an
immediate interaction and do I have an
intended impact my videos on the
audience I kind of almost tried to give
myself a motto once which was gonna be
educate inspire entertain that's kind of
the three things I want to do and some
videos it's more like just one I kind of
want to make all three go into each
video that I make but yeah that's really
what I want to do I want to educate you
guys on stuff that's cool and I think
it's cool I inspire you to do your own
things and have fun watching it really
sounds cliche when you say that and
that's it
props it's nice to stick it out to the
end because Christ that was a lot of
questions thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much for being an amazing audience
for leaving all these questions for
caring enough to think about good
questions to ask and for watching this
video I hope honestly blows my mind
every time I look at my number of
subscribers on my channel you know the
dream is to get this them like a hundred
thousand get one those cool plaques but
you guys are the best thank you
so whilst we've been on the very long
walk here we've been able to go possible
to lots of different sections and it's
worth pointing out that the diversity of
science here is incredible so we just
gonna cost climate change solutions
forest ecology crayon
but YouTube described the concert